من جانبي اقله الرئاسه الاوكرانيه انه لا
توجد ما تسمى بعمليات خاصه ولا اهداف لنزع
السلاح بل ان هناك حربا شامله بداتها
روسيا واضافت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه في
تغريده على تويتر انه يمكن ان تكون للحرب
نهايه واحده وهي خساره المعتدي
ومعاقبته بقسوه حسب قولها
الرئيس الاوكراني في الاردن
عن الضربات الروسيه لمنشات طاقه
الاوكرانيه لن يمنع الاوكرانيين من
الالحاق مزيدا من الهزائم بمن سماهم
الغذاء واشار الى ضروره الاستعداد لاي
سيناري على حد تعبير
اوروبا
سيحاول ان يجعل هذه الاوقات اكثر ظلمه
والصعوبه بنسبه لنا لقد بذلت روسيا كل ما
في استطاعتها هذا العام لكنها تصعد من
دعيتها بعد ضرباتها الصاروخيه على بلادنا
وعلى قطاع الطاقه الاوكرانيه اعرف ان
الظلام لن يمنعنا من الحاق المزيد من
الهزائم بالغزاه ومع ذلك يجب ان نكون
جاهزين لاي سيناري
هذا وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيدم
الدعوه الى حرمان روسيا من مقعدها الدائم
في مجلس الامن الدولي واضاف كليب انك
يفسدون موقفها اليوم متسائلا اذا ما كان
لروسيا الحق في البقاء عضوا دائما في مجلس
الامن لافتا الى ان الاجابه هي انها لا
تستحق حسب قوله واوضح ان هذه المساله لم
تطرح بعد في مؤتمرات صحفيه او بيانات عامه
لقاده الدول والحكومات لكن يتم تناولها
على مستوى ادنى السؤال بالفعل هو ما يجب
ان تصبح روسيا حتى لا تشكل تهديدا للسلام
والامن